welcome back to the cordon digital
podcast everybody i'm here in studio
this week yeah you are you're in person
wow you're much higher resolution than
i'm used to you might not recognize me
here in
actual but this is jake actual rather
than jake
virtual virtual jake virtual today's
episode not sponsored by modelo but
i mean
who doesn't love a good modelo
i'm i'm i'm i find myself coming back
around
to those kinds of beers yeah you know
like dos equis sapporo corona yeah
sapporo's japanese they have their place
yeah i don't know as it's coming from
someone who's like um i'm a particular
fan of hazy double ipas and yada yada
like i don't know i feel like
the beer industry is beginning to lose
their way lose their luster
lose their brains talk about let's dive
into that a little bit i don't know i
was literally chatting with jenna about
this the other night too because
what what wait you feel like it's losing
its way a little bit
like getting too wacky it needs to
return to it too many micro blues bro i
like i like wackiness uh so
i don't know a while back when i
i feel like ipas have actually changed
over the years like
and and this is completely unfounded
maybe there's nothing to this and i'm
just it's a personal feeling especially
as people evolve over time maybe my
taste brewmaster wren gives his takes
i'm just thinking about it because the
amount of ipas that are out now
is like an order of magnitude more than
it was just a few years ago five ten
years ago like
they're not even remotely as many as
there are now so i just got to wondering
like
has that affected all ipas in general
just because there are more because
now you have all these farmers who farm
who like grow hops and stuff like that
and they used to have a certain amount
of
customers clients
farming clients so you think big hops
has gotten so big that the quality is
decreasing i am speculating that that
might be the case big hops and think
about science
and and suddenly over the course of a
few years you're having to be like i
need to produce way more and that's
gonna fundamentally change the soil and
and all of this stuff and i'm just
wondering if it's
leading to a decline of ingredients now
i'm using hops as an example but it
could be for a bunch of just mass
production right yeah i don't know again
i have no idea i have no idea but i i
i have had a couple beers really like
what's your theory
that's your theory okay that's true i my
theory is that the influx of
demand for specifically ipas
a certain type of beer
has
shifted the
sort of the supply chain to meet that
demand and that supply chain
or the
the need to create more supplies for all
of these things has adjusted how the
water has made quality i mean i can
speak i can speak a little bit to that
yeah you have a lot more actual brewing
experience than i do well no not even in
that context cause we're doing honey
mead which is a totally different thing
but like uh lagunitas okay yeah so
that's from petaluma california that's
where they started and i grew up in
nevada which is literally just 10
minutes south of there sure so lagunitas
was our local little home brew i've been
to the brewery yeah yeah that's great
you can go have a well used to be able
to go there and have picnics on the lawn
and stuff and it was it's cool you can
like you could pick up your beer from
their store because you can't get it
anywhere you could get it you know in
certain brew brew like micro brew shops
okay sure but now
lagunitas is everywhere
and
the quality has definitely like
decreased last time i tried log bunitas
i don't know there's just like you said
you can't put your finger on it oh yeah
it's like intangible
there's something about you know that
that mass-produced product they never
can capture the magic of the small batch
and i'm not i'm you know i wouldn't
knock lagunitas as a company like oh
they're great you know good for them i'm
i'm proud of them for becoming
successful
yeah but yeah like it trips me out
though that you can walk into almost any
like gas station or 7-eleven and there's
like lagunitas and it's like wait that
used to be like we would like
go out of our way to pick up like a
growler of lagunitas like
that's that's when you know a beer has
become mainstream is when it it goes
into the the gas station circulation you
know it's like
there are only a few if you can walk
into a gas station and all of the beers
there like are the beers that you will
find in any store yeah
yeah and now log uniqueness is one of
those and it put ipa i think it really
like that was the first ipa to really
like go viral you know
well isn't it that uh ipas are just
easier to brew
in terms of like it was something and
they put more hops in to preserve it
better yeah i think i think you need a
little less
i what i understand i don't i'm not a
brewer but what i understand is
obviously i'm not a brewer do i even
need to tell you that you're not a brand
um is is what i understand is that
there's just a little bit more room for
error when you're making ipas and you
can do them small batch and to make
loggers apparently is just a lot more
of a process where you need a lot more
material and
like
well like the term ipa stands for india
pale ale and that comes from you know
what like two to three hundred years
it's a segment of probably history
well then here's what probably is that
history yeah exactly guys welcome to
probably history where are we like what
we give our takes on what we know what
we don't know and what we think history
might be go ahead
the east india trading company didn't
they didn't they like condense down the
beer to be like more thick so that they
could transport more so that it would
last longer on these voyages across the
ocean and they came from india probably
so
they went to india i don't work the
other day probably history the other day
at lunch probably it was it was me nico
i think you were there and dean
um
we dean bought something at the market
it worried markets this hip japanese
market so hip well not exactly 20
dollars they cater to like you know
super hip nice drinks
and he got something called hop water
which is just
it's fizzy it was not there for this
okay it's fizzy water with hops and
they're like it's like beer and you know
nico was basically saying like so what
they just took the worst ingredient in
beer that makes it taste horrible and
then ruined water with it
so and we were talking more about it and
apparently
hops we were looking up like what are
hops like because none of us actually
could pin down what are hops used for
apparently it's used for the
preservation
um again probably history i'm probably
wrong leave a comment correct me tell me
how dumb i am but anyway apparently
india pale ales you're right they were
used to preserve them on long journeys
they put more hops in there okay they
would have a much fuller bolder flavor
yeah and i'm not a particular fan
specifically of hops like having some
hoppiness is fine but like it
it derives this sort of like bitter
flavor profile and i always like to my
favorite ipas are the sweeter ones
that's why i like double ipas rather
than say like imperial ipas because they
tend to be sweeter they have more like
maltiness to them
um
yeah like one of my favorite beers for a
while was this one from golden road
brewing they're based in glendale
california i used to live really close
to them uh they made this beer called
wolf among weeds
loved this beer and then one day
it was different and like
very different this was like maybe two
or three years ago it changed i was like
it was completely different beer like it
didn't remotely taste the same and i
didn't like it like not liked it less i
straight up didn't like it i've since
come around
i l
and maybe that's because i forgot what
the original tastes like
yeah i don't know i don't know something
i guess what i was starting by uh this
whole conversation started from here one
single model comment that i've just
found myself kind of appreciating like
good light good lighter beers sometimes
because some of the ipas i've had lately
are just they're too bitter they're too
heavy they're just not good do you mess
with me with uh belgian wheat ales are
you uh i'm usually not a fan of belgians
they're not good people
there's fighting words in here
like i'm thinking of like the like the
weissens type
they always
i don't know how to describe it other
than i feel like i'm just drinking the
water that's been sitting in at the
bottom of a pig farm says the guy who
drinks ipas
about pig farms i don't know there's
some sort of like weird like farmy
flavor to them to like a like a belgian
or like a heff i can sweetie beer it's
that wheat flavor i think i i don't know
where you're coming from it's being half
big
they don't have like a pastoral quality
to them
interesting it's because belgium is all
farmland so i mean it makes sense right
you know it's all gonna take that way
but uh
yeah i'm a fan personally hill garden
garden yeah those are nice those are
sweets is that where you
is that a garden for
it is a place in belgium
okay sure it is not a garden of horrors
i wasn't going to say [ __ ]
well would the hoes be where all the
pimps be
it is not a garden where you pay women
money for sex
one time i actually went to her garden
i i wound up in hogarth in belgium one
time
because i was there in last time i was
over there visiting my family i got a
really cheap plane ticket and i was like
man this plane trick take it back home
is really cheap and then i figured out
that i accidentally selected the wrong
airport and that there's two airports
like there's like charleroi which is in
the french southern part of belgium
charlotte charlotte wall what however
you say and then there was uh brussels
but like for some reason
it's called like brussels south or
something on the website portal so i
thought it was brussels so we had to
literally drive in like an hour across
belgium and my cousin and that doesn't
sound too bad
it was
really chaotic and stressful because
like i did not realize until it was like
you're heading to the airport like that
morning and here he was like oh we have
to go down to freaking like bologna to
like take you to the airport so we drive
like we're just
busting through belgium and like my
cousin he has like it's like an old like
milk truck or something i don't know but
like it's like big farm dude dude it was
amazing we gave everyone milk trucks and
uh
it i got to see all of belgium and dope
we like stopped at this like roundabout
and like i look over and i'm like wait
we're in ho garden there was the hoe
garden brewery and i was like dude this
is my favorite beer that's awesome okay
anyway so that was a happy little silver
lining
airport fiasco yeah dude
that's it's real though it's like
there's i feel like there's nothing more
stressful than being late to getting to
the airport because you don't know what
it's going to be like at the airport
guys it's the time for the podcast
sponsor today we have storyblocks you
know everything i'm about to say right
now don't you you've been listening to
this podcast i'm proud of you good job
if you want to spend more time creating
in less time going through the slog of
finding b-roll and stock assets for your
projects consider a tool like storybox
we use them all the time here at
corridor digital we've been using them
for years and that's because they're a
great product and a great service from a
good company not only do they offer some
of the best high quality 4k b-roll in
the land but they also offer audio
images after effects templates motion
graphics and more and they have over a
million assets if you get their
unlimited all-access plan you can
download all one million of those assets
and use them in any project commercial
or personal and it is demand driven
meaning that they are constantly adding
new things to their site hey people want
this people want that they're paying
attention they're active about it it's
not just set it and forget it so if
you're interested in adding that tool to
your toolkit head on over to
storyblocks.comcast to get started
that's storyblocks.com
corridorcast just another great product
from another great podcast thanks for
listening and let's get let's get back
to the episode
okay what's your closest call at an
airport where you still got on the plane
or
or alternatively what's your worst
airport story oh gosh
where's the airport
oh my god oh that's
because i had to go to the airport to
pick up the guns
the guns at the airport fiasco can you
imagine
loading a giant bag
a giant duffel bag where the guns don't
even fit they're all poking out of the
duffel bag walking yeah through an
airport carrying guns hey can i try to
in my car
i'm alone and uh
very basic protocol for teams
me just preface this there's a very
basic protocol for taking firearms
or replica firearms into an airport you
need to be in a hardened locked case
you present them at the desk for
check-in you say i have firearms to
present they take you to a back room
where a tsa agent uh inspects them
puts a slip in it takes them away that's
it that's all you got to do
super simple but we were like young and
stupid and we didn't know
how to do this process
and so
so what video was this for it was this
was the moment yeah the tank video yeah
so you drove a tank through uh yeah 17
18 because clint was involved i think it
was 2018. well we had to bring all these
props to minnesota
yeah it was the second half of 2018
that's right so it was like yeah it was
yeah three four years ago and what we
just decided to bring a bunch of guns
because we couldn't decide on the guns i
guess yeah we didn't know you never know
which one you're going to need you know
we just wanted it
to be fair tactics for different
environments different enemies
so yeah to be clear these were all fake
weapons most of them didn't even work
versus fake weapons
but if you bring a replica firearm into
an airport it still needs to be treated
as a real firearm and so
i wasn't at the airport when you guys
were trying to check in and all that
stuff were all three of you guys there
well you thought i was not right there i
was i was at the office i was literally
at the studio i was there with christian
yeah
i was already in minnesota oh okay sure
i'd like to get there yeah you guys like
took a bun you shipped a bunch out there
or did you drive it out there i forgot
because we were bringing the rest why
was i out there early
so me clinton christian had you know a
bunch of duffel bags full of weapons and
other
costumes yeah attack gear
your standard core door ships this is
your standard corridor
and we're like rushing to the airport we
have like a lot of gear and there's like
you know a couple people helping us load
it all in
and uh
yeah the duffel bag with the gun barrels
sticking out comes up
and uh
they weren't too happy about that
they were just like we can't we can't
allow this in and we're like oh no it's
uh plastic they're just airsoft they're
fake they're fake and they're like yeah
we don't care
again i wasn't there i'm presuming yeah
so
they wouldn't let us fly with them but
our plane was about to take off and
luckily there were some props already
out there i think but yeah we're like
okay well this is like
a lot of airsoft gun props that we need
so
what are we gonna do like we can't just
leave these here because and they'll
throw them away yeah that was the option
it's like well
you can't take them
but you can't like
miss your flight and take them back no
and you can't leave them unattended yeah
they were they were literally going to
throw them away
until i forget the guy's name but one of
the one of like the bag workers there
christian you remember it yeah he was
cool
he was a saint he should be we should
put a mural we should put a mirror we
should put a picture of him i felt bad
he was he was a foreign dude i think he
was from africa i don't know which but
he had like an accent and whatnot and he
was a very nice guy you got you sent me
his number and i was trying to get there
and it took me almost an hour to get to
the airport because it's la
and we gave up on the guns we're like
okay like we can't take these guns but
jake's gonna kill us if we have to leave
all and throw away all these what am i
gonna kill you with i don't have any
guns
dude you're out in minnesota with a tank
okay that's true yeah we're going to a
tank range i mean yeah so i texted this
guy that hey i'm on my way to pick them
up because he was sticking his neck out
for us he did man and i didn't realize
how far out he stuck it until i get
there and realize his supervisor is
furious
she was not happy
like
yeah uh fortunately because i i text him
he's like okay see you soon and he's
like are you here yet i'm like no i'm
not even close and like his texts kind
of started getting more and more nervous
uh
and i finally like pull up this is also
in the area where i had that that
convertible and the the engine would
overheat
oh man
pulls up in an overheating convertible
at the pickup and drop-off at los
angeles uh international airport and uh
runs out a bunch of uh
long rifles in a duffel bag from the
security
to the car and broad daylight i threw
them in the back seat and they all just
and the smoking car took off yeah that's
like actually what happened
and i talked with the supervisors like
please don't punish this guy and she and
she was like i won't
he learned his lesson
i'm like that's ominous as hell wow but
i'm gonna hope and trust that he did not
get fired but i worry that that's what
it's like working for the federal
government
the federal government that runs the
airport tsa
tsa
well oh he was like uh like i think he
worked for the airline no he was
sticking his neck out he's like no you
can't go to tsa here i'll take him out
and like he he waited there with the
guns
and let us go to our flight and we would
have missed the flight he was like one
of those guys who who like will carry
your bags in from the car like at the
yeah drop off
man
there's some quality soldiers out there
ladies and gentlemen i really wish i
remember his name i remembered it for a
long time it doesn't matter now though
we could find another text chain about
it or something
yeah it's christian do you have the text
chain i don't know if we should
pull up the text chain
no i'm not yeah i'm not gonna
so
that whole shoot though let's continue
on this journey yeah so that was when i
was like okay now i'm heading into work
and continuing on whatever it was i was
working on so then they get there
you guys land
and then
you're we immediately have to go to
uh
mink what was it min it wasn't mint it
was lakota
lasoda
soda minnesota let's soda medicine
outside of saint peter
and uh
we get to the
they're like yeah yeah we have the rv
we're like because remember we were
going to buy an rv yep and they're like
okay because we're going to run over an
rv the whole thing takes place inside a
rv that someone lives in yeah yeah and
so we're going to run over an rv with a
tank and that's the goal
and then they're like okay we have the
rv
i'm like you guys bought the rv they're
like yeah we have the rv you don't need
to buy the rv because i was going to buy
like a
non-working or like barely functional
five thousand dollar
rv who's they
uh the uh production okay
in the production in conjunction with
the facility
had purchased the rv as opposed to like
salmon eco yeah and it was a long like
double wide it was a big trailer
um
and uh with the polyester curtains and
the redwood deck yeah it was it was
red nice piece there clark
a nice
whoo you see this sick battle axe well
this is in honor of son of a dungeon
what we're filming here in the studio
this week but enough about what we're
filming in the studio what i want to
tell you about right now is today's
sponsor manscaped now just in time for
the new year the whole new year new you
thing right nobody likes to hear that
phrase but you know what you do like to
hear where you can get some great
personal hygiene products for a
reasonable price and that's where
manscape comes in they have this year
for 2022 the performance package 4.0 the
flagship item of the performance package
is the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer this is the
fourth generation of the classic trimmer
that manscaped is known for it's got the
advanced skin safe technology to reduce
cuts and nicks in unwanted places and it
also has a 4000k led light so you can
see a little bit better and those hard
to reach hard to see places it's also
got a little travel toggle thing so you
can turn it on and off when you're
traveling it's overall just a fantastic
trimmer and with the performance package
you can get that and more you can also
get the crop preserver and crop revival
formulations which are perfect to have
you smelling good and feeling good all
year long and of course the performance
package comes with the shed travel bag
and the anti-chafing boxer briefs to
make a nice complete package for when
you're on the go or when you're at home
just to get you going for 2022 and you
can get 20 off plus free shipping if you
go to manscape.com and use the promo
code cord or cast right now that's
manscape.com with cord or cast as the
promo code and you'll get 20 off plus
free shipping anyways
let's get back to that episode
anyways
we get there the rv is completely gutted
pretty much
it was not a meeman's home right we were
supposed to we were supposed to have a
whole scene in there
where there's like
i'm sorry
but there's a whole
kitchen scene there's a scene in the
bedroom there's there's all kind and
it's supposed to be set up like it's a
normal home
[Music]
and there's nothing in the rv yeah when
you say nothing are you talking like
open floor plan nothing like literally
empty
walls
yeah sharp splintery wood so we had to
make it look like it hadn't wasn't ready
to be completely demolished
and so these guys rush
to the thrift store
i remember hearing this story it's in a
video they clear out right
they're gonna do like two or three trips
we got like truckloads of
of old meemaw furniture and
as we were doing that sam was like
hammering [ __ ] into other walls and like
trying to fix cabinets
yeah yeah a full kitchen facade yeah we
like we made full cabinets we did a
whole living room completely with
candies in the glass man
oh you didn't get the potatoes no i
never took it home because i had you
getting potatoes dude
it would have been perfect they just sit
there on the counter don't they you know
that's what sex they had this really
cool
hand carved hand hand-painted potato box
and it had some it had some like homey
joke on it like potatoes and onions it
said i believe potatoes and onions yes
golly i wish i would have taken that you
know we can i'm sure we can find you a
potato and onion box yeah but not like
that that was like hand crafted by a
like the son of a german immigrant you
know true
true man that that thrift store though
like
they just had like the day of the year
oh yeah
can you imagine coming into work and
being like whoa whoa you're taking
everything so then they were great okay
then they set it all up
and it it worked you guys pulled it off
it worked yeah for the purpose of like
hey we're going to destroy this with a
tank you can't tell no you cannot it
looks like a plausible mimosas home and
that's all that matters yeah and then
they were like oh and by the way we
don't have a tank we have a armored
personnel carrier with no barrel
so you're gonna round it over with that
yeah and also the world of tanks logo is
on the front of it
so
there's that
looks like you managed to paint out
relative success
but uh that was that was a wild shoot
that was a wild shoot i just remember
the bugs dude yes you and clint about
the bugs you guys would not stop they
were filming in the woods and clint was
just it was just going
that's unpleasant i've had that
it's just a normal day in minnesota yes
it is in minnesota summer
well the thing is like we get there and
i'm like why do all these houses have
screen porches who the [ __ ] i'm a
californian i'm like
why would you put a screen on your phone
oh my god it's so ugly yeah what the
[ __ ] it's really thrown off my vibes
throw it off my beach vibes bro now i
know
the bugs it's like i gotta be hungry for
dinner still i don't want to be eating
bugs all day sit down who needs dinner
when you got bugs yeah i know that's
what i was saying dude
did you grow up eating bugs oh so i grew
up eating bugs
you know what we used to do three
squares you know what we used to do for
fun when i was growing up two bugs
probably i used to go i was the youngest
of four siblings and i was always the
rat in the pack
they used to me and my neighbors and my
brothers we used to go out
into the woods and there was this train
track
that went across the river the saint
croix river which separates wisconsin
and minnesota
and we would just go out there it's this
high bridge
that goes out like
300 feet over the
over the
river
oh didn't we boat underneath yeah
yeah
yeah it looks like something out of like
that's super [ __ ] high up like a
steampunk movie oh yeah
yeah it's not like a futuristic looking
bridge no it's like an old truck it
looks like an old truck it's an old
truss bridge
um and uh
so we would just go we would just go
down there and there was a rumor that
there was a ghost that haunted it
so we would go down there and look for
the ghost and then you know throw rocks
and
yeah you go over the river yeah yeah
smoke cigarettes jump off
like to dive or something
jump no we never jump each other that
way well there was a rope swing down by
the bottom of it
so you could really pointed that out
never still there people would commit
suicide off the top of it that's how
high up it was
that happened a few times
so that's what i did
and there was a lot of bugs
well that's what i didn't you didn't
have to tell me that i assumed so
just depending on what time of year i
was playing these super nintendo if you
had fallen off the bridge you probably
would have been like slowed by all the
bugs in the area
there's a tale of a kid who jumped off
one time and got caught by dragonflies
[Laughter]
he started falling and then they caught
him and he's like
the fizzy popping juice or whatever that
willy wonka drinks i don't forget what
it's called yep that's what happens
busy lifting drinks fizzy popping juice
no we all have stories of like just
being dumbass shitty kids like our
parents saying go play in the woods and
then we'd go dude i grew up in louisiana
where we had this bayou down the street
from our house
and i moved away when i was 12. so
i haven't been back since but we had
this this
little
area of woods next to this bayou creek
and there are alligators in it what is a
bayou it's like it's like a cross
between a creek and a swamp okay and
it's like it in a marsh it's the bayou
you know it's a low back water
and we and they're like someone had
built a tree house here years before uh
i'd been born and and like expanding so
there's like this two-story uh tree
house that had this bridge going to an
actual tree it was super cool and we'd
explore all this other stuff through
this whole wooded area it was a lot of
fun it was really cool it's awesome and
alligators just don't care
they're like sometimes we don't know if
they're alive because they just sit
there
not doing anything you didn't mention i
mean i assumed there were gators but
oh yeah no they're later than anything
at all it's falling in the water your
parents just let you play with the
alligators well okay i'm not like
swimming in the in the actual water and
there's no danger of falling into the
water it's not that much
kids these days weren't out there
playing with alligators but that's where
my fierce spiders growing up
because they had these banana spiders
that are literally the size of like an
adult human palm
and
and and they would have like these
abdomens or thorax whatever it's called
that would like it was shaped like a
banana and they had these crazy designs
on them they're freaky looking super
freaky and their webs would literally be
like 10 feet across between trees and
they would sit right in the middle and
so they'd be
floating and like we're talking
something that if it hits your face it's
the size of your face and they're just
floating in the air at face height dude
awful
there's nothing i'm sorry
i think
there's nothing worse
you still have trauma from this dude i
do
man but i've gotten a lot better because
there's so many black widows uh here in
la and i have to go through and kill
them all with bug spray and so i've i've
killed hundreds of black widows over the
last year
yeah the bags bags spiders are just
creepy and more brown
oh yeah dude that's and they're like you
have brown widows in your room no so
like the first apartment
my old apartment the first one i moved
to in l.a it was an old um building and
like the window they were like those 70s
windows that were slat glass
and there's no it doesn't close all the
way like little guys can just come
through right and my bed was right next
to that window and there's a garden
outside
and like literally like once a month i
would under my bed i'd do the sweep
for the brown widow guys i killed the
sweep yep gotta do this because i know
there's a little brown widow nesting
under my bed and every time there was
and they would just
chill you know they'd be fine we got
along but and then i'd kill them but
they look just like black widows they do
but they're bone color yeah exactly and
they have an orange i used it for a
while i thought they were black widows
until i saw an actual black widow and
i'm like oh my god you are
pretty
like pretty terrifying pretty terrifying
absolutely but they have this super like
specular reflective blackness that is
like
it's
oh they're not like black it's a bizarre
type of black it's hard to describe and
it was immediately like oh
yeah all these other ones are not black
widows because this is a black makes the
red pup it does yeah
yeah
creepy spider kill him
there's a creepy spider that i don't
know if brown recluse spiders are out
here
but these things
they're in texas
and
they'll they don't like
they're not aggressive and they're slow
they're weird creepy slow spiders
they have obviously they have eight legs
but they're they like it looks like
almost when they walk that their legs
are broken like they don't you know
normal spiders like this and it walks
kind of consistently and fast even a
black widow these ones walk like this
and their legs are like bony and crooked
and they have these little violin shaped
bodies
and they have huge fangs
and they're poisonous
um and do they go in the house a lot
i've seen two of them in my house okay
and i've killed them
yeah and then one time one was on my
backpack i told you this story on the
podcast but a few like it was many
episodes ago but i was heading to la and
i grabbed my backpack
and i went all the way to the airport
and then i went to go throw something in
my bag
when i was at the airport and i opened
up the flap on the top and and at the
top of the flap underneath there was a
brown recluse spider just sitting in
there and i had taken this thing all the
way from my closet all the way
to the airport terminal
and it was just sitting there and we've
come full circle yeah to airports and we
have couples the tsa let you bring the
spider through tsa
uh
yeah i had to fill out a form
they confiscated yeah um and they gave
them back to me when they landed
yeah
but yeah but these things have gnarly
huge fangs
which is why they're able to
oh yeah bite through human skin they get
you
yeah man there's a
there's
one story from i used to go to like
scout camp every summer when i was in
scouts
and they gave us these like old lean two
tents that were like old military
surplus lean twos
very simple canvas tents but do would
condensate on top of them every morning
and
inside was warm
so we'd wake up and every single morning
there would be hundreds
of these they're they're a subspecies of
arachnids
but they're not actual daddy long leg
spiders oh i know what you're doing they
have one body segment instead of two i
know i know exactly because they're the
type of quote-unquote spider that
everyone thinks is that exactly and
they're commonly thought as a daddy long
legs but yeah they have the one the one
kind of it's almost like an octagonal or
hexagonal like body segment and the ones
that huddle together yes
and they live in packs dude they are
communal spiders they don't wave webs
right um and they just they're little
like you know
scroungers they scrounge little bugs
little scraps moss daddy longlegs are
cellar spiders
right yeah yeah yeah they they go by
many names right but these guys well
those ones
though they're like little like uh like
those little uh from spirited away those
little posters i was cutting some trees
in my yard uh this summer and there was
this oak tree that's next to a fence
and it's a wall it's a stone fence and
and on the other side of the oak tree on
the back side of the oak tree in the
little corner
was an entire ball yeah it looked like a
hair ball it looked like a
there were so many of them they were so
creepy sitting in there yeah i didn't
disturb them because they were outside i
mean it was like their natural
environment i don't find those ones
quite as scary but like yeah certainly
like you'd wake up to him and they'd
just be right above you yeah because
like that was pretty lazy guys i'm
officially over this conversation they
love those
i'm not i'm not liking this anyway
airports airports
when are you going to confront this
phobia dude i did we made a couple
videos about it well yeah but i feel
like you know you're still you still
haven't fully confronted it
i mean i've been doing it privately like
i've been saying i've been i've been
battling the the widows
at my house battling the widows i had to
i had to
i'm not really scared of ghosts
but i had to
but they freaked me out a little bit
and there's uh above my above my garage
uh it's like dark up there and um
there's a light that i turn off
and every time i turn that light off i
feel like there's a freaking ghost up
there so one day
i just said you know what ghost i'm
gonna go up there i'm gonna go into your
territory and i went up there in the
pitch black dark and i just sat in there
until i wasn't scared anymore
it
sucked
but now i'm not now i'm not as scared to
go up there at night
i'm not that afraid of darkness afraid
of the dark you know
unless they're spiders
i'm afraid of the potential
of the spider in the dark of us of a
single spider in the dark
yeah you know it's funny it's like i can
i can look at a spider and i can be near
a spider and it's not that big of a deal
but the moment
the chance or possibility of that spider
making contact with me in some capacity
becomes
non-zero
i'm not okay would you ever handle a pet
tarantula no
tarantulas aren't even
uh pool skimmer the other day what
yeah
it was like i don't know it wasn't
full-sized it was like maybe that big
but it was just
yeah i didn't know what to do
i like tarantulas because
i don't know i i'm i'm less afraid of
tarantulas because they're so slow
they're these big chunky things that
chunky things
they're going about their day trying
they're like they're they're the
tortoises of the bug they really are
they're like
dude it's all a big bug it's all big bug
it's all big big
big hop and big psych dude don't let big
psychology tell you what to think
okay
don't let it big psychology is that is
that the is that a son of a dungeon
inside joke yeah that's right don't let
big psychology control your thoughts man
break free
yeah the big bug industry has been going
on for too long man
you got that the appetite for the bugs
we've got the monopoly on bugs
bugs used to be higher quality and then
you know mass production
and then mass production happens
and then that decreases
i don't know i i going back on that that
beer thing though i may be just
completely out of my mind and
and none of that's true it's just what i
feel is true so therefore it's probably
true right right that's what i have
that's how you wear how faith works it's
how you feel yeah it's all about how you
feel if i feel something in your gut
makes with mixed with what you based on
your preconceived notions
what is what you think is probably true
what sounds plausible not even what's
probable what sounds plausible mixed
with your own feelings equals fact
equals fact well now it does yeah yeah
you know yeah
it's impossible to live outside of a
bubble
so we shot son of a dungeon yeah day one
day one first two episodes yeah we did
that was that yesterday that was by the
time this comes out day two will be shot
as well
oh yeah so this is coming out next week
okay yeah we're shooting day two on
friday it's how's it going in your
opinion it's going well yeah like i
think it's going pretty well i uh i had
a lot of fun on monday
i'm more
i don't know how to describe it it's not
that i was inexperienced last year i was
but
i
it's more so the fact that like i'm now
i now have that experience playing with
you guys playing with sam having this
whole like sort of expectation of how a
story can play out having all the whole
table i have very little experience
playing with such a you know an ornate
table
um there's also i have more experience
knowing my character you know like
knowing what how my character should
feel about certain things and therefore
how i should respond right in certain
situations
uh yeah i'm very excited for how for how
my my character's journey will hopefully
play out with everyone yeah
no i feel that too i i think we're all a
little bit more comfortable playing in
the characters but there's another
element here too that was new for me as
well last year which was
how do you because we're not just
playing the game we're playing the game
for camera too yeah it's a show we're
making a show how do you because there's
another aspect there normally when you
play you can are you in character you
out of character you play how you want
to play based on your comfort level with
the character your comfort level with
the game yada yada but now there's this
third element which is
playing for the edit
so like when you're being very specific
about when you're talking to another
character you're not talking to like
when i'm talking to bob when
when warren is talking to bob
jake is not talking to ren
like but warren is talking to bob and
bob is talking to r to warren yeah
that i feel like we have
done a lot better job of so we're making
a much bigger effort to make that more
cohesive yeah this year it worked fine
in first in the first season but you
know one of the bigger notes from sam
and uh carmichael was just that
if we stayed in character and treated
the other you know fictional characters
as if they're there in front of us like
let's
this is role playing this is yeah we're
supposed to be not jumping across lines
when it comes to
well if there's people having a
conversation and your character's not
there you can't just jump in and go yeah
oh you know unfortunately sam's very
good about moderating that and knowing
when
uh that should be enforced yeah but uh
but also you know it's like his whole
thing is that like when you're talking
to a character that character is me talk
to me right as if you're talking to that
character
uh as opposed to uh does does this
person agree with our sentiment and
she's like why are you talking about
this person i'm right here in front of
you like right
that's sort of that and so that's kind
of how we're thinking a lot with with
our interactions and i feel that
actually is going pretty smoothly yep i
definitely think that's going to help a
ton with the immersion and um
well this that's just going to tell a
better story
at the end of the day so
more on that to come
and uh
man
it's also weird how my
perception and memories of season one
are warped by the fact that it now lives
in a video yeah you know it's like i'm
sure you guys experience this all the
time with the regular videos we put out
all the time where it's like you have
all these memories of making the video
but the only actual like archive like
tangible archive of those memories is
the video itself and so
sometimes you don't remember certain
aspects of what happened uh because of
how the edit plays out maybe it
re-contextualizes certain moments and
that recontextualization ends up
becoming your memory over time you know
our memory is not yours
your memory is documented
in the form of video
yeah no i totally know what you mean
though like uh it does
it does have that effect
i i had totally forgotten
that i had the whole horn of blasting
thing ready to go with the actual horn
in season one yeah uh like i'd totally
forgotten about that and then because i
i'd watched that last week
because my whole thing was that i wanted
to surprise all you guys that i had an
actual horn and when it came time to
blast in the horn i had freaking clint's
bonky horn
and i had forgotten about it so i
surprised myself i was like whoa
yes it worked it worked on me
i surprised myself because i totally
forgot that i'd done that
so i was very happy about that
yeah anyway
yep there's some big monsters this
season oh my god season two
sam was really going hard yeah
he i think him and carmichael both said
hey these guys are too powerful we need
to hit him with everything we got
because as soon as season two starts
you are right in it
yeah i guess i don't i don't want to
spoil what the the first encounter is
but it's like immediate you are in it
right away
because season two literally begins
not even a minute after the end of
season one
like we we start off the season still
damaged from our final battle it's just
a continuation yeah it's like
it's not like oh
we we've now had this we've gotten down
to you know whatever uh we've now
started this new campaign it's like the
campaign never finished and we're
finishing it now but now we're high
level we're starting off this campaign
at essentially level nine
which if you're not familiar with dnd is
a pretty high level it takes some time
to get there so your level changed but
your damage didn't change well we start
at level eight and then there's a long
rest we explained that yeah
this is starting to get into like the
the technical mechanical details of dnd
yeah we're we're shifting over to like
a long rest based
uh every every day that we shoot where
our characters level up which is
essentially what we did last year but
we're doing that based off of xp so
every time we have a long rest and
there's enough xp well okay no no no i
mean like
last year at the end of every day of
shooting which was about two episodes we
would level up our character so we went
from level five to level eight over the
course of season one right we started
off at level five because it's a show we
don't wanna you know no one wants to
watch us
fling sticks and so
this is a small subtle detail i don't
even know if it's worth talking about
basically instead of ending the session
with the level up and starting the next
session it's like you end the day
with
uh you level up your character you go
through the the steps of you know
choosing your new spells or your skill
tree etc
but those don't go into effect until
you've taken a long rest in the next
episode
if that matters are you guys like
showing that on in the episode you guys
choosing your new spells and everything
or is that oh yeah
no but it now creates this
situation this incentive
to
get into a position to take a long rest
yes
you know like we get dropped right into
it and all of us are like almost dead
and we're like we gotta find somewhere
to rest it's like a major motivating
factor for us
there's no motels in cecilton
yes
there's people in christ
but it's fun i i find myself being very
excited going forward for this season
also i i realized i just had to really
really get into the mind space
of
d and d for for our session because we
filmed what tuesday so i pretty much
spent most of monday thinking about d
and then at night i was just re-watching
episodes and just like that wasn't the
only thing i was thinking about and i
really feel that that really helped
put me into a position to be able to
perform on camera while also playing a
game you know it's i don't know yeah no
i was doing the same thing i was working
on my
character all day and
it's yeah it's moments like that where i
i find myself
getting it getting what
actors mean when they say they talk
about prepping for a role and all the
stuff they have to go through in order
to just do something because it's like i
don't know acting
some of the times isn't that hard you're
just like you say some words you try to
like emote a certain way and that's
acting but it's like that is such a
superficial
take you know like real acting requires
being a character and being a character
takes surprising a surprising amount of
effort on that note
i think this is the perfect place to end
the podcast because
nicholas has something very special for
everybody in a few weeks on uh corridor
crew youtube so stay tuned for that
consider subscribing and uh that's all
we can say because friend's in the room
um so remember that batman surprise
video
thanks for watching everybody
except batman don't don't thank him
he never he never came
back you want to handle it you want to
hear three shoots to the wind
yes from son of a dungeon
do i do i
alright where's that sacred
three sheets to the wind three sheets to
the wind
i van around the world and back again
three sheets to the wind is where i
begin
until my time comes to an end
and we'll all go sailing on
when the rulers are buried at
[Music]
but it's
how it ends
three
sheets to the wind
three two one